okay so the boys season three episode
four is now out and it's time to take a
butcher's at all the easter eggs hidden
details and things you missed in it
there's also major callbacks to the
comics in this entry and we'll be
talking about what originally happens in
them and comparing it to what we get
here so far the season has had
homelander teasing that he's going off
the deep end but this episode he really
goes supersonic oop spoiler alert and as
i'm sure you can guess we'll be talking
about everything so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the boys season 3 episode
4. now we open the episode with the real
life american tv show solid gold
featuring soldier boy this series
starred in 1980 and it ran for eight
years hosting several singers and
dancers like what we get here the show
was criticized for being pretty corny
and the new york times stated it
devolved into becoming a parody of
itself due to the soap opera-esque
storylines that were sold throughout the
series the tracks were also heavily
mimed meaning that it was all image
which of course mirrors vote soldier boy
performs the song rapture by blondie
which made its tv debut on solid gold
it's credited as being the first ever
rap video broadcast on mtv but it has a
bit of a controversial legacy to it
debbie harry is often mistakenly said to
be the first rapper which yeah isn't
true and it devalues cool herc a bit who
is said to have kickstarted the genre
however you have others that say she
recognized the art form and brought it
to the masses which helped to propel
hip-hop into the mainstream there is
some reflection here in soulja boy who's
credited as being a hero but in reality
he killed mm's family mother's milk is
of course a massive rap music fan and we
occur to him as a kid watching the
performance with his parents there's
also flashes of a toy call and we
learned in the newspaper clippings that
soldier boy forced his family's car off
a road which killed several of them go
to the flat iron building which was also
the headquarters of the boys in the
source material huey confronts butcher
about v24 and though he berates him for
taking it come the end of the episode he
himself also injects it too hughie ends
up punching through his security guard
in russia which actually plays somewhat
on the first time that he killed someone
in the comics after being injected with
compound v huey ended up putting his
fist through the bloney [ __ ] who he and
the boys had been spying on huey didn't
know his own strength and he felt guilty
about it for weeks after until blonnie
returned as a zombie judah v basically
firing up neurons in someone after they
died a hamster wrapped in cling film
that had been had been shoved up as a
will not going to that that actually
ended up climbing out of him which huey
ended up keeping as a pet we even get a
potential not of that hamster later out
in russia but we'll talk about that more
later on in the video now occur to
cameron colton's show and a bit of a
correction from last week i said that
termites movie was called rocket romance
and it was actually pocket romance i had
pocket in the script but i misread it
however that doesn't excuse my actions
and i want to apologize to everyone i
let down last time i see you i hear you
i grow now when we last left them mr
stelios supes had just announced that he
and starlight were a couple however what
he's here to talk about is the birthday
rant and how the media are reporting on
it homeland is cited as being fake news
and he pays lip service to there being
powerful people within board that pull
the strings we then could immediately to
stan edgar meeting victoria nadia newman
the three of which all have major rocks
in this entry homeland ends up ousting
edgar through vick who exposes him
during a press conference edgar here
uses whatever he can to try and keep
homelander in line and he even suggests
using fcc fines for him dropping f and
cc bombs eh the show's main theme at the
moment is all about power and what
people will do to attain it we of course
have homelander the most powerful man on
earth who's dismantling the bureaucracy
to get to the top there's then edgar
who's attempting to use red tape to stop
him and also billy who's taking v24 at
the expense of his own principles
starlight wants to quit the seven but
she's being coerced into staying with
them the deep was willing to eat his
best buddy timothy just to get back into
the group there's also several
characters that fit this theme
supersonic was warned not to join the
team but the allure of power was too
much a train is running on borrowed time
and if he uses his power again he could
potentially have a fatal heart attack so
now he's trying to gain power through
other means namely by using his image to
give him ins to social causes lastly is
huey someone completely powerless who's
now stuck with feelings of jealousy over
his soup's girlfriend and her
quote-unquote boyfriend when talking to
starlight later on he says he'll save
her for once but homelander arrives and
spoils all the fun he signs huey's
freshly minted cast and almost pressures
him into talking about their sex life
although he stands up to homelander
starlight is the one who steps in i
think it's this feeling of inadequacy
that makes him end up attempting to gain
power himself which we'll talk about
later on huey also carries on wearing
banned t-shirts and we can catch him
donning one for foreigner now newman is
terrified that homeland will come for
zoe in retaliation and by the end of the
episode she ends up injecting compound v
into here as a way to protect her at
this point billy and frenchie also go to
meet little nina in the comics the main
arc that this episode is based on
started issue 11 and it followed the
boys as they went to russia to
investigate supes whose heads had been
exploding in it we discovered that there
was a variant of v that had been placed
in a certain ones which made them
ticking time bombs this was overseen by
little nina who was selling this ration
on the black market on behalf of bought
there's a scene in the source material
where she met with james stillwell who
in the comics was the ceo of the company
also huge shout outs to everyone who
pointed out that the kid who's a
teleporter at red river is actually
madeline stilwell's son whether he'll
come back or not we don't know but him
being able to teleport explains how he
managed to escape the explosion at the
end of the first season thank you
everyone who corrected me on that i see
you i hear you i grow now in the comics
nina was a completely ruthless killer
who had over 2 000 body count like ryan
aries mom
[Applause]
the rumors were that she had taken over
the saint petersburg racket after
killing her father and she was brought
in by vort to help stage a q she was
tasked with injecting all the russian
ones with an explosive form of v and
they would then launch a coup on the
government to take over nina believed
that at this point she would swoop in
set off a radio frequency to make their
heads explode and that she would be seen
as a savior however board gave her
return and they were going to be the
ones who appeared to save the day they
also put an explosive on her plane which
we'll get into in just a bit now on the
opposite side of this the boys were
investigating it all and they met with
love sausage a russian soups who made a
cameo back in season two nina orza had
been hired by vor to take them out but
they killed her goons and butcher went
to her plane here he found the world
employee learned the plan and then he
told him to put the explosives in her
vibrator it was said that after nina
killed her father and she refused to
feel the touch of a man and as the plane
took off she went to use it which blew
it up it crashed into the side of a
mountain and butchered then went to
where all the soups were and using a
radio device that actually worked he
blew all their heads off now butcher
pays off cherie's dead and gives little
nina an extra 100k for her troubles
however nina still wants the girl and
we're gonna see how this evolves come
the rest of the season now a train goes
to ashley and also actually who
belittles him for wanting to go after
blue hawk ashley says black lives matter
is her favorite hashtag and talks about
her instagram being all black squares
which was what was used at the time to
show unity with the movement when it
comes to vault it's all just social
gestures without actually meaning it and
this is seen in the commercial for his
energy drink turbo rush his commercial
is parodying the kendall jenner pepsi ad
in which he gave a can to a police
officer completely de-escalated the
situation and was a bit tone-deaf jenny
got a load of backlash for it and a
train is clearly questioning whether
he's doing the right thing anyway it's
theory time theory time hear your time
your time now there is this weird thing
around soft drinks in the series that
might just be a coincidence but i think
it's still worth talking about fresco
was brought up several times in season
two as being something the church of the
collective constantly drank there were
theories that helped with brainwashing
and turbo rush also being used to
control the police might hint at
something else big reach but that's why
it's called theory time every time
period time
next we see maeve training with his
sword in her room gonna drop some heavy
spoilers for the comics on this bit so
if you don't want the show spoiled then
skip to the next section now in the
source material mae was the constantly
drunk alcoholic that her reputation now
paints her out to be however she did
have a moment of clarity towards the
back end of the run and she went head to
head with homelander using her sword she
ended up attacking him however because
this was a prop it just broke in half
this could later be referenced in the
sex toy scene as i believe hers snaps
away in the same way that the sword did
in the comics maeve was murdered by
homelander and i think this scene is
setting up a showdown between the pair
now at this point starlight goes to her
to talk about the weapon capable of
taking down homelander russia is the
perfect place for this too and we see
several pieces of graffiti of the
character symbolizing their hate for him
homelander is very much a representation
of western superiority and they run
broadcasts on the tv mocking not only
him but also huey this is played by cmn
obviously a parody of cnn yeah great
great easter eggs in the video now
mother's milk wears a rough rider's
t-shirt further carrying on the motif of
him wearing hip-hop bands little nina
has found the location of the lab but
she wants the boys to carry out a hit on
a target first this involves kimiko
dressing up as a woman of the night and
in the comics but you hire these same
sort of ladies to distract the pilots on
nina's jet also i know what they're
called yet youtube are a bunch of see
you next tuesdays when it comes to
mentioning anything like that so i'm
just steering clear now starlight goes
to supersonic and tries to recruit him
into hashtag home fight and he jokingly
plays off still being in love with her
however i think it's clear he actually
feels that way and is just gauging her
reaction at a meal for the seven
homelander gives them all tacos showing
how he doesn't respect him at all and
it's clearly just used in a derogatory
way along with a constant spanish that
he drops this mirrors the end of episode
3 when he also said the following
amigos
romano
now at this point a train brings a blue
hawk a racist suit that we discovered
kirb stumped a man returning from work
last week which was a nod to american
history x blue hawk very much represents
police brutality and blue is of course a
color that's synonymous with the force
huge shout out to david ruse who pointed
out on our last video of that in the
army the term blue falcon means a lazy
soldier and blue hawk may also be based
on the soup groundhog from the comics
and the boy's diabolical with some help
from cassandra deep brings up that blue
hawking homelander share some of the
same base so he decides to not do
anything ashley gets a tip on the press
conference and homelander ends up
belittling her she later uses the same
put down on cameron coulson showing how
he's having a negative effect on
everyone around him she also brings out
a homeland to strap on later on
cementing this idea that she's now using
him to be dominant towards others look
at me getting all psychoanalytical on
this subtext now the idea of homeland
enforcing people to act negatively is
seen in a train who confronts the deep
outside the seven's office homelander
did the same thing to him at the start
of the season and this also pulled from
the comics after a train joked about
starlight giving him homelander and
black noir a bj in front of stillwell he
then hit him homeland was very much
about keeping things business in front
of the big guy and this team is clearly
starting to fall apart a train knows
that deep got the plane tape and deep
down deep knows that he leaks
stormfront's past super sonic ends up
trusting in him but he ends up snitching
on their plan in order to get back into
his good books it's all a quest for
power and the only one who doesn't seem
to want it is kimiko who hates the fact
that she has to kill she enters the
mansion to the sound of poison by mel
biv davao before we hear a russian
version of i will survive
maybe a bullet to the head eh now this
scene in which he heals is very similar
to the one in x2 in which wolverine also
pushes a bullet out of his forehead
after being shot there are of course
also the dildos that are all in line
with members of the seven kimako
questions whether she's doing the right
thing which is then murdered by newman
who announces edgar's corruption on nnc
which no price is for guessing is also a
satire of cnn homelanders says it's the
dawn of the seven and that anyone hiding
is now no longer gonna have his
protection
go to ashley's office where we see that
the seven mural behind her now has all
its members this juxtaposes its earlier
appearance in the series where it just
had five homelander travels to vic
crosses some boundaries and hands over
the evidence that edgar was planning to
turn her into as he later says he taught
her to play both sides which is
something that he's done throughout the
series he of course has right-wing
politicians in his pocket and newman is
an aoc parody that's on the left he also
benefits from using the supes but he was
the one who tipped butcher off about
stormfront victoria is just playing
whatever side she can and it is possible
that she will follow her comic book
counterpart and end up in the white
house she takes the compound fee from
homelander to protect her daughter
showing that she does have an achilles
heel this makes her weaker than edgar
who was willing to throw her in harm's
way if it came to it here he goes to
butcher and pleads for v which he ends
up taking due to how weak he feels at
board tower homelander and edgar end up
having a talk this feels like it
massively pulls from a scene in the
comics in which he went to stilwell he
remarked that his heart rate stayed
steady throughout which is reflected in
homelanders comments here about how
relaxed gray is unbelievable 80 over 60.
your entire life is imploding and it's
as if you're reading [ __ ] john
grisham in the end homeland is surmised
that stillwell was the real superman
because of the calmness and power that
he had edgar tells homelander that now
he's out the way no one will cover for
him and the world will slowly start to
realize that he's bad product this sort
of mirrors the source material and in
the comics stillwell delivers this
devastating speech to him think about it
this is par for the course with you when
have you ever done anything remotely
interesting or original what have you
thought of to do that the lowest spec of
this pointer species couldn't were they
to be granted your level of power and
what next destroy an airliner dismember
more families that kind of thing a
spoiled child's personal auschwitz it's
so petty it's actually quite
embarrassing now james was a
perfectionist and he viewed v creating
these sociopaths as being a failing he
wished he could forget he ends up
leaving and it's going to be interesting
to see where things go the boys go to
the lab and mother's milk brings up
rocky iv a film that is of course about
the us versus russia after discovering a
suit of hamster called jaime they're
ambushed by swot and this leads to
butcher unleashing his powers along with
huey now the name jaime is actually a
reference to the comics and after huey
saved it from the bloney [ __ ] he ended
up calling it that however when the
villain showed back up he referred to
him as herbie so bit of trivia that bit
of trivia that i know you love and it
all builds to a head when they come
across soldier boy whose body's inside a
container this is similar to how the
winter soldier was stored in both the
second and third captain america films
similar to bucky he's been captured and
experimented on by the russians and it
very much riffs on the captain america
backstory that he of course plays into
he now has powers like havoc from x-men
and he can shoot concursive blasts out
of his chest there's a feeling of
terminator to the music and he ends up
taking down kimiko she's no longer
healing and i think they might end up
injecting her with more v in order to
save her life this might jumpstart her
healing factor and we see in huey that
his broken arm is now back to normal
after injecting it mother's milk says
there's no team anymore and this girt
punch is murdered in the throat that
homelander gives to starlight the
original superman film had he and lois
going for a flight together and though
this scene is initially set up like this
it's got a big reveal homelander has
messed up super sonic's face so bad i
couldn't even tell if it was him when
doing the breakdown and he says that
this is what will happen to huey if she
steps out of line he states that they
are who people is shipping and them
alone for the future episodes this might
mean that if she even sees huey again
that he could end up killing him however
on the opposite side of this huey has
access to v which will level the playing
field the boys taking the substance in
the comics was something they did early
on but the series has weirdly done
things the opposite way around the focus
on the seven didn't come until much
later and a lot of things that they're
referencing in the show now happen in
the first omnibus this is the same with
v but it has added some tension to it i
really can't wait to see how the show
evolves and i've loved these first four
episodes we're past the whole waypoint
and you can kind of see it all falling
into place with homelander getting worse
and worse and worse and worse worser
than these breakdowns now this episode
pushed the stakes even further and with
him ousting edgar and also killing
supersonic there's no way of knowing
where things could go next personally i
think we're g for a showdown very soon
but he might end up holding on to
starlight so that she can't warn huey i
also think that maeve's death is
probably right around the corner and
with edgar out the way he's gonna be
fully off the leash either way another
great episode and i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers you want emails to watch
them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the first three episodes
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over all the easter eggs in them
talk about the things you missed and
it's definitely worth checking out if
you haven't checked it out yet if not
then thanks for singing through the
video i've been paul i'll see you in the
next one take care peace
you